Matthew is with us in Providence Rhode
Island hi Matthew how are you hey Dave
how's it going
better than I deserve what's up hey so
my wife and I are in baby step two we
have a hundred and ninety thousand
dollars of debt besides the house good
lord what yeah mostly private student
loan debt of mine what are you a doctor
or lawyer I'm a stupid musician a stupid
musician yes sir
actually I'm not currently working with
music right now I'm making my I'm
actually in insurance so that just goes
to show you the biggest stupid tax I've
ever done
good lord what is your degree did you
get a degree No so even worse oh my lord
how much of this one hundred ninety
thousand did you spend on that not
getting a degree thing yeah about a
hundred and fifty
yeah I've been beating myself up the
last however many years so what is your
household income now sir it is 150
that's good news that's yeah you got a
big you got a big hole in a decent
shovel good okay and so almost all the
190 is student loan then or 110 of it is
yes so it's most things to them there's
14 and credit cards and about just under
five of a car that we're going to pay
off very soon yeah okay so you're
working the debt snowball in so we're
working additional or one baby step two
the question is so my plan or I plan I
should say was to finish this in about
three years with the income that we have
yeah and we're going to upgrade in house
we have a family of four after after we
after the question that my wife proposed
was our house never what a hundred
thousand worth of equity in the house so
she was proposing what if we get down to
about the $80,000 marker so in a few
years two years maybe cut cut the debt
snowball by a year by selling the house
at that point finishing it off and
renting while we save up for it's still
the same thing
time to get into a new house though yeah
I mean that's my original plan was to
just work that that's no boys you're
gonna get to it you're gonna get I mean
because here's the thing if you sell the
house and pay off the debt early you
still got to put the hundred thousand
back in an account before you buy a
house right right it's you're just
swapping in pockets with your money here
you're not gaining any time on your
calendar towards getting a new home so
I'm gonna sit right there I'm gonna sit
right there house moving is expensive
emotionally and financially so I mean if
you had $300,000 worth of equity and you
still had 200 to buy a house with later
that'd be different but you got a
hundred and it's gonna be gone I mean
when you do this so now you gotta start
over saving for a down payment
and so you don't really gain anything on
your calendar doing that no hey I'm glad
you're working your way through it it
sounds like you got it lined up and hey
we've all done stupid stuff in the past
it's in the past
put it behind you keep but plow through
it clean it up and learn your lesson
teach your kids don't do this so you
change your family tree now man way to
go good for you
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]